and before we get started I'm going to
start this video off with a necessary
shout-out to my old boss AJ for months
he was like you need to watch the show
Deadwood of anyone I know if there's
anyone who could appreciate the dialogue
in this show it is you watch it so now I
finally watch Deadwood raise your
glasses to AJ you beautiful bastard and
your awesome soul
[Music]
Deadwood now you know me if there's one
thing I like I like me some good
entertainment
I like good movies I like good TV shows
I like good videogames hell I would like
a good girlfriend if she could entertain
me for at least 12 episodes of season
but that's yet to be found so I stick to
the superficial entertainment so
Deadwood was a series on HBO that ran
for three seasons before getting
cancelled about a real town called
Deadwood in South Dakota in 1877 there
was a big gold rush going on that
brought a lot of people there and was
interesting about the town of Deadwood
is it wasn't under the United States it
didn't fly a United States flag it was
not part of the United States so it
didn't have any of that government
meddling and that's what I find really
interesting it's ultimately the most
lawless town you've seen now first
you're like okay Timothy Olyphant plays
Seth Bullock he's gonna be the main
character any more or less is it first
then you have in McShane playing Al
Swearengen he's gonna be the villain and
he is at first or his mood calls him
budget Timothy Olie font used to be a
u.s. marshal and he's like I'm leaving
that behind I'm going to Deadwood I'm
gonna open up a store with my friend and
we're just gonna live low out-of-sight
out-of-mind problem is you can't be a
former badge and then come to a place
called Deadwood and just blend
eventually you're gonna be like all
right that was I'm gonna go
stick my nose in that because I feel
like that was just unjust now you're on
the radar of Al Swearengen played by Ian
McShane and I'm telling you I'm gonna
really concentrate a lot on ian mcshane
because he's really at the point of the
show he carries the entire show for
three seasons he is the male ego without
the mask and necessary to survive in
civilized society Ted would not be in a
civilized society you just get the male
ego in all its raw form which is Ian
McShane as Al Swearengen budget and it's
awesome his dialogue is some of the best
dialogue you've ever heard in anything
delivered by a master of his craft he
steals the entire show yeah at first he
was the villain then psy comes into town
played by powers Boothe the guys name is
powers I'm not quite sure he ever knows
he's being filmed he comes in to
Deadwood he's a bigger dick than Ian
McShane sir all right the enemy of my
enemy involves you're a bigger dick than
Ian McShane so I'm siding with him and
then more people start coming into town
bigger fish and it's really about Al
Swearengen ian mcshane surviving in that
world
no I run this town you douchebags are
not going to take this away from yours
he calls him which I found
interesting I have not heard the word
said so many times and had it at a
point you're like it's really about a
bad word has a flair to it you don't
really hear it these days why did it
become such a bad word at a point I have
no idea
Deadwood uses it with style I like that
I had a school teacher once who was like
I have heard every swear word on the
face of the planet I will give you a
pink slip or write-up or whatever the
hell those things are unless you can
swear and impress me if you can swear
and impress me I won't write you what
because I like being impressed
Deadwood does that it swears with style
doesn't matter what word they use
however if you end up gravitating
towards Ian McShane character and his
dialogue which I believe you will do you
might just see Deadwood as the most
misogynistic show ever made if misogyny
does offend you somehow I might advise
you to let Deadwood pass you by or he'll
watch Deadwood and find out how much
misogynistic dialogue actually intrigues
you reality the situation is it is
misogynistic and most guys will probably
like the dialogue don't hate us for a
genetic says it's just what we like
there's probably a YouTube video out
there with Al Swearengen 'he's best
lines look it up Al Swearengen is the
best written character with the best
dialogue delivered in the best way I've
ever seen in a television show now as
much as I keep praising ian mcshane in
Deadwood i do recognize that it's a
collaborative effort with a myriad of
different characters and all of them are
just great the people of Deadwood are
the lawless outcasts of civilized
society it's not pretty
but you can't deny that it is intriguing
season 1 Ian McShane has your curiosity
season 2 he has your attention season 3
he has your allegiance bummer is the
show gets canceled after season 3 and it
wasn't like when they were writing the
show Rome and halfway through writing
season 2 they were like it's going to
get cancelled so we're gonna speed
things up and wrap it up it doesn't get
its wrap-up it just leaves off with you
thinking all right season four is gonna
be badass it's gone now however and it'd
be in a real town based on real people
you can go onto Wikipedia and find out
what happens to Deadwood and the people
in it which that's really cool if the
good caretakers of Wikipedia have
noticed a lot more traffic on their site
is because there was once a show called
Deadwood now there is not if you require
resolution with your TV shows I would
say you're going to leave Deadwood kind
of air
however if you love great dialog and
great writing Deadwood dude
Deadwood I'm glad I watched it the lack
of resolution does leave a sour taste in
my mouth but you can't deny the Flair
that this show has especially if you're
a western fan why haven't you watched
Deadwood already like right now now I'm
in a bit of a Western mood I'm playing
Red Dead Redemption right now I'll get
you a review on that I have myself a
couple of westerns I want to give
reviews for keep in mind not all
westerns take place on earth just saying
but those reviews are coming and they're
coming pretty soon so have you seen
Deadwood what did you think of it what
did you think of the character Al
Swearengen comment below let me know and
as always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]